se nella vita ti piace fare un qualcosa
che ci devi applicare egli portarlo
avanti cheat sheet bene a tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti in questo nuovo
video siamo dio è più cosa c'è il 74 in
attesa che skype louis ii non ero mai
abbastanza perché c'è sempre roba nuova
madonna 174 episodi ogni volta che lo
guardo e dico mamma mia quanti ne ho
fatti poi però guardo minecraft ita di
sori e dico che forse potrei anche
lasciar perdere
se ti fai a satisfied lavoro non rischia
che a pronunciarla sta roba non sono k
non solo inglese sorry sorry e satisfy
lever amena fastidio livelli dove devi
andare contro le cose da tutto il
contrario
19 lista eccolo questo è bellissimo
questo è bellissimo nobel do vabbé vabbé
10 su 10 questo è veramente carino
l'inizio invece a cagare proprio questo
effettivamente era satisfying just do it
e tipo l'impossible un po strano specie
che ci prova è andata bene poteva andare
peggio poteva piovere ma che succede al
mio poco scusatemi ma in realtà dove la
madonna
steig arno di nadar l'obiettivo non è
prendere la moneta e toccare il
traguardo che qua capo danza
mi è piaciuta soprattutto la testata che
ho dato alla fine c'è proprio fino a qua
ragazzi ancora ancora costruisci un orso
tu mi spieghi perché ti sei svegliato la
mattina e il lettore facciamo livello su
april dove dove faccio un orso
ok tu e nella vita il sacco di
aspirazioni poi parlo io che siamo al
settecento settantaquattresimo episodio
ma vabbè scelgo papa vegas
ok scegliamo la bocca e hanno il naso il
naso quadrato babe nola già cocktail
bello nasa cocktail questo va bene
next ben nove questi non li possono
scegliere questi qua azzurri bellissimi
ragazzi questi sono i livelli della mia
vita
cappello la professor layton e si va a
comandare abbia finito
che bello barba bene questo era un
intermezzo bmx coors erano un sacco si
faceva una corsa con bmx però l'abbiamo
fatta bene volevo con le piroette i giri
e la morte
sua madre ma ora fate in 3d tra l'altro
beh sì c'è scritto nelle nuove corse in
3d e non sono anche capaci ad andarci
tensione c'è molto di peggio ragazzi
l'impossible non riesco a fare da una
vita quindi attenzione però io ho sempre
avuto problemi dei livelli con la bici
perché ancora pc non sono dopo il
massimo anche nella vita reale non so
andare in bici nota sono caduti in un
fosso sofficemente perché una macchina
mi è passata di fianco ma neanche troppo
vicino a rio che mi son cagato addosso
attenzione eccolo non era niente di chè
prove spyphone lo spy ecco questo questo
per avviarci proprio nei livelli per
cominciare uno dei migliori perché lo
spy phone tiffany tifate di passare il
calendario prima ancora di fare tutto il
resto che voi non è che ci voglia skille
in spite folle bravo solo culo in base a
come tiburtina
onestamente ne è bipress space to start
signori ogni tanto usciamo dalla confort
john non ci ricordiamo più che siamo su
happy trees però va bene c'è questo per
carità non voglio disegnare la grafica
chami mi sembra abbastanza tanto vedi
quando sei quando sta in piedi normale
non ha le gambe piegate quindi hanno
fatto anche degli script e cammina no va
bene sto male e fatto benissimo click
anything a beni fini non è verde unica
la porta quindi click porta di end of
the demo ma come hai battuto sto
bordello e prefinito la come mafai la
roba quasi un parkour bong look at war e
se come io voglio morire e quindi no
fermi ci stiamo parlando link questa
estasi estasi
è la madonna c'è un pugnetto sfogato
questo togliamo ok e questo come polli
prima che sono iniziate attenzione ma
esplodono 666 esplodono esplodano perché
il numero di satana aiuto non va più
indietro non puoi più tornare indietro
non è che si resetta va bene rimarranno
così tutta la b pro bello mi ha dato zoe
di fan charbel livello 73 per cento in
prossimo al meno male che che bello
questo non possiamo che dove entrava
dentro prima che
prova a sfidare il packaging voglio
vedere se riesco a finirlo senza llull
ecco senza senza da bombe impossibile
però che l'h madonna senza la bombelli
issimo belli siamo questa incredibile
aspetta che bella idea per una volta c'è
per una volta datarne che fa schifo che
fanno schifo però alcuni sono poco fa
tipo questo qua è uno standard colori ha
proprio fatto un concept diverso destino
ha vinto solo una gamba ei gol ci sono
fermi fermi fermi come come come sarebbe
possibile ma come no va bene ne va
questa la 174 episodi questa è la
vittoria migliore di qualsiasi
impossibile abbiamo lo giuro thangram
page albè ok con non vuole non volevo
non volevo mi scusi fa niente volevo
semplicemente andare avanti io non far
fuori anche abbiamo fatto la fila eccolo
proprio colore non volevo che succedesse
da qualcuno che non so bene chi però
sempre su tutte quante le frecce in
bocca ok è un pezzo di gamba fa bene a
sono arrivati molto bene grazie
beh sembra carino teoricamente se non
fosse per questo finale orribile
o scassato un po tutto ma fa niente è
importante aver vinto next password
troppo dei quattro mini è un po come se
fosse quella specie di brake che alla
fine scontro sono rilassanti ragazzi
cioè l'unico tipo di livello veramente
mega rilassante motor bike woman baby e
cervelli va bene
next quanti gli altri di lobby swing non
hanno vinto questa settimana il migliori
livelli cebook porca vacca questo non
solo meritano neanche sono vivo fa
niente devo centrare il buco in mezzo
c'è la fa l'ho preso stranissimo ma l'ho
preso la bene next day perfetto fino a
qua tutto a posto
tranne le gambe ma tanto vale non ci
servono massaggio gratis saltino lo
facciamo un saltino che sono tutti i
massaggi tipo alla schiena tutte robe
belle mi piace apple sta diventando il
gioco rilassante una volta era un ray g
game arrivati più verso la zona relax
meno male perché dopo anni tipo vengono
stupito quando niente ormai italia
parliamo
dovrei fare invece chiaro che l'ing ok
invece che fare lo zelig dove racconto
nella mia vita
dovrei fare è prince dove la contro la
mia vita e rocket lì invece giocarlo
seriamente svolte o un altro live tanto
bert cosa diavolo è va al contrario ma
come aiuto ai anno sono morto
gestisco bellissimo che bella idea che
bella idea non si trova al contrario è
veramente giocare per vincere bisogna
dire
[Musica]
ma io avevo schivarlo non si può
schivare non si può scrivere niente come
faccio a schivarlo a posto volendo
l'aspettano è veramente difficile
proteggersi ragazzi però per una volta
sono nei loro panni
attenzione sono vivo ma sono vivo cioè
nel senso la spada sono vivo non mi hai
ucciso non vale ara fighissimo la posso
anche quasi salirci sopra
volendo ragazzi sono vivo non mi ha
ucciso quindi hai perso gli utili hai
perso ai perdo 16 a stendermi sopra
sarebbe il top
sono ancora vivo però ecco come ho detto
vabbè ragazzi però fare un ultimo 99.99
per cento hard il che mi fa un po invece
veramente di prima perché finora ho
fatto visto in queste opzioni rieti ci
sono fatto le peggio cose quindi
qualsiasi livello io non lo temo
oggi raga oggi va oggi ci si vede che la
maglietta vogliano ma solo ragazzi però
ci sono delle volte in cui pregio senza
il motivo ma pro legge che sara 170
avanti al prossimo sarà episodi speciali
quindi rimanete connessi sintonizzati
schiacciate quella bellissima campanella
che vedete cintas iscriviti e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video e
ragazzi
[Musica]